اذا كنتم تظنون ان عام 20 22 كان صعبا على
عامه الناس بسبب تضخم وتاثيرها على
الاسعار فان الاثرياء لم يسلم ايضا
الافرياء لم ينجو من كل هذا القلق حتى ان
وكاله بلومبرج تقول انهم ذاقوا ما صنعوا
واعتبرتهم سببا في كثير من المشاكل
الاقتصاد العالميه اخذ مئات المليارات من
كبار الاثرياء لكنه في نفس الوقت سمح
بدخول 200 ملياردير جديد الى القائد لكن
مره اخرى الحديث كله عن لهن ماسك الذي
اصبح اول رجل في التاريخ يخسر 200 مليار
دولار من ثروته في عام واحد طبعا ماسك
جنوب افريقيا
سنذهب لنص مع القصه من امريكا حيث صنعه
هناك ثروته الى للتسليم
مره جديده يحققوا الى الماستر رقما قياسيا
هذه المره بخسارته اجبر ثروه سجلت في
التاريخ 100 مليار دولار نعم الرقم صحيح
ولكن الوضع ليس سيئا الى هذه الدرجه فلا
تزال قيمه الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
سبيس اكس وتويتر تبلغ
137 مليار دولار وهو جيد بما يكفي لا يحتل
المركز الثاني في قائمه اغنى اغنياء
العالم
كان نمو ثروه الون ماسك مدفوعه بالاساس من
حصته في تسلا بعد ان تجاوزت القيمه
السوقيه للشركه تريليون دولار لاول مره في
اكتوبر عام 2021 لتنضم الى الشركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه ابل و مايكروسوفت
وامازون
والقناص باللون
السبب الاكبر في الانزلاق الذي قضى على
حوالي
675 مليار دولار من القيمه السوقيه للشركه
هذا العام بالاضافه الى تغريدته المستمر
على تويتر وسلوكه غير المنتظم بشكل متزايد
بكل الاحوال قد يرتد سهم تسلى ويمكن ان
يصبح ماسك مره اخرى اغنى شخص في العالم
ولكن سمعته باعتباره عبقريا تعرضت لبعض
الاضرار الجسيمه عام 2022 تقريبا بقدر
الضرر الذي تعرضت له ثروته الشخصيه لصباح
العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن
[موسيقى]
سنه 2022 كانت قاسيه على اغنى اثرياء
العالم تريليونان دولار كانت خسارتهم
العام الماضي لتصبح ثروتهم 12.7 تريليون
دولار بعد ان كانت 13.1 تريليون دولار عام
202168 مليار درهم في سنه 2022 بعد ان خرج
من دائره الملياردرات نحو 329 شخصا اكثر
الدول التي تاثر اثرياءها العام الماضي
اذا خرج نحو 77 مليار صينيه من قائمه فورس
لاثرياء العالم متاثرين بالعقبات
الامريكيه على قطاع التكنولوجيا روسيا
الخاسر الثاني بعد ان خرج اربعه وثلاثون
مليارديرا روسيا من قائمه الاثرياء بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا تزال الولايات
متحده الامريكيه تتصدر العالم في عدد
الملياردرات ب 735 مليارديرا في حين
احتفظت الصين بالمرتبه الثانيه ب 607
مليار درهم
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي تنضم لنا تورى كماجات العاده
في فقره الاقتصاد الصحفيه والاعلاميه
الاقتصاديه سمر الماشطه سمر يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك معانا صباح العربيه ايلون ماسك
يصبح اول رجل في التاريخ يخسر 200 مليار
دولار في عام واحد من ثروته كيف خسر الى
الماسك هذه الثروه الكبيره ويعني مكانه
اغنى رجل في العالم
موجوده فعليا في البنوك وخسرها هي قيمه
دفتريه من ممتلكاته فما مبدئيا طبعا تسلا
اللي هو يمتلك 75% منها
خسرت 800 مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه
منذ ان اعلن ماسك على استحوا هذا بتسعه في
المئه من تويتر في امريكا 800 مليار دولار
خلال اقل من سنه خلال بضعه اشهر انا قلت
تسعه اشهر تقريبا الان شلون نحسب القيمه
السوقيه الى شيء معها هي الاسهم اللي
موجوده في لشركه مع الاسهم الموجوده في
البورصه اللي شركه كما في او همم سعر همم
السهم في هذه الشركه فلهذا هناك
فيلاكتويشن يعني همم نقول تردد عالي مره
تطلع همم ثروته مره تنزل على حسب قيمه
الاسهم طبعا واحده من الاشياء اللي فقدها
ايضا هي اللي تراست او الثقه همم لبورد
الموجودين بالنسبه واليوم
يمكن بتنحيه عن اداره يوم قيمه تسلا من
1.2 ترليون دولار الى 333 مليون دولار فقط
هاي اخر مره شيكت بحسب سعر الاسهم للشركه
اهم يعني سمر سهم لانخفض 65% يعني كان
اسوء فقر الدم الان 70% البارحه ايضا كان
هناك المزيد من الانف الخساره انه نسمع بس
اليوم لما نسمع انه خسر 200 مليار دولار
وهو لساته بينكت بينشر تغريدات عايش حياته
مرتاح والله
هل هذا هو حاله انكار بتصيب المليارديريه
لما بيخسروا اموال ولا هذا مبلغ بسيط لا
اكيد لا بس هو اعتقد انه ماسك حاله خاصه
واعتقد هو يحاول الاحتفاظ اليوم بالماء
وجهه لهذا يعني ما يحاول ما يبين انه هو
متاثر بس ما في ملياردير ثانيه اتصرف
بالطريقه اللي هو يتصرف فيها هو معروف انه
عندك نوع من شخصيه غريبه يعني فما اعتقد
اي واحد نخسر اذا خسر اي مبلغ من الاموال
راح يزعل طبعا ومن الملفت انه اللي اخذ
مكان اليوم همم بير نعد عنهم اللي هو سي
اوه تبع الفي ام اتش انه بيرنات قبل عشر
سنوات تحديدا في 2013 كان رقم 10 على
قائمه الملياردورات اليوم هو نمبر وان
واكتسب تقريبا 110 مليار دولار خلال
تقريبا اقل من ثلاث سنوات طبعا لانه هو
مسؤول عن قلبي ام اتش اللي هي واحده من
اكبر شركات بضائع الفاخره وكم ما تحدثنا
في حلقات سابقه كان في هناك مبيعات كبيره
جدا في المبيعات الفاخره وبالتالي ارتفع
سهم في ام اتش وارتفاع
شهدنا سقوط اباطره العملات المشفره
تراجعوا اسهم شركات تكنولوجيا عملاقه هل
يمكن القول اليوم بناء على هذه الحقائق
انه الثروات مبنيه على منتجات حقيقيه
وملموسه هي الاقوى يمكن نقول خلينا نقول
حسب الظروف يعني كما نذكر ايام مكرونه لما
ارتفعت اسهم التكنولوجيا كلها ليش لانه
كانوا الناس محبوسين في البيت فطبعا عندك
اسهم مثلا زوم كانت مرتفعه او مش اسهم
قيمه زوم كانت مرتفعه تقيمها كان عندك
يعني مايكروسوفت تسلا ابل كل الاشياء اللي
كانت تفيدنا وقت ال همم بس نرجع مره اخرى
اللي صار مع همم عندك البيتكوين وغيرها
يعني هناك العديد من الخبراء يقولون هي
مبنيه على هواء مو شيء حقيقي كانت راح
تسقط بالنهايه في كل احوال بس عندك المواد
الاساسيه اللي هي الاغذيه الخدمات
الاساسيه مثل الصحه والتعليم هذه دائما لا
يمكن الاستغناء عنها فبالتالي شويه تكون
فيها اقل فلاك تويشن او اقل يعني يعني
بس سمر كمان انا بس بدي افهم انطلاقا من
اللي عم بتحكوا هلا وعلى قصه البنت كمان
خلينا نرجع لانهم ماسك انه 200 مليار
دولار هو كيف خسارهم اسهل ثانيه وكان
حسابه البنكي ولا بنحكي عن اسهم تسلا الا
عم نحكي هون تحديدا عن اسهم تسلال الان
لما يحسبوا ثروه سواء مؤشر بلوتوث
شلون يحسبوها يحسبون رقي ايش قد عندك اسهم
بشركه خاصه او شركه معلن عنها يحسبون كل
شيء عندك ثروات الجول يعني المجوهرات
اليهود المقتنيات طبعا البيوت المحلات
ايضا يحسبون حتى اللوحات الفنيه كل شيء
عندك مقتنيات وهاي كلها مع تحفظ يعني هي
ممكن تكون ثروه بعد 10% اكثر طبعا هناك
كثير
من الاعلان عنها للتعرب من الطرائق مثلا
فيعني هاي لسه في تحفظات يعني ثروتهم ممكن
تكون اغلى من ذلك بكثير فيتم تتبع هذه
الثروه كمؤشر الان شلون خسر ماسك تحديدا
بالضبط هي من تسلا لانه تسله اسمها ب 70
في المئه مثل ما قلنا قبل قليل وبالتالي
همم همم هو همم نزلت من قيمتها السوقيه
مثل ما قلنا هي قيمه دفتريه وليست اموال
حقيقيه او كاش يعني شكرا